Is the screen visible?
Yes, sir.
I will show you the student's collection and then we will see how we check the collection in the reports.
For the collection, I have opened the student's profile.
Here we have the option of collect fee.
You can go to the collect fee page from here.
The second option is fee, then collect fee.
In this, we will search the student's admission number or student's name.
I did it with 697.
I have opened the student.
Now, as the June month is going on, I have April, May and June month fees.
I have April, May and June.
I have Rs. 33,000 showing here.
Overall, my fee is Rs. 78,000.
I can select the next term from here.
After that, the month will show up here.
If the parent has to pay the fee for the next month, then we can select the next term and collect the fee.
Yes, sir.
For example, I have to do it for 3 months.
I have to do it only for the April month.
I select April only.
Out of Rs. 23,000, I have to receive Rs. 15,000 only.
In that case, I will select Rs. 15,000.
Automatically, it will be deducted from my admission fee.
Okay, sir.
If I have to deduct Rs. 15,000, Rs. 10,000 from my admission fee and other charges from tuition fee,
then in that case, I will select Rs. 10,000 and deduct Rs. 5,000 from my tuition fee.
Is that clear?
If I have to deduct less amount from my admission fee and complete tuition fee for April month,
then I can change it here.
Okay, sir.
If we select the reduced amount here, then the first fee will be deducted from there.
And if we have to do it manually, then we can edit it and do it from there.
For example, if I have two heads,
I have to deduct less amount from one head and do more in the other.
I have to do as much as Rs. 5,000.
Then I will deduct less from here and do Rs. 5,000 from here.
Then my amount will be shown here.
Okay, sir.
If I have to take admission fee only and not tuition fee,
then I will un-tick it from here.
So this amount will come here.
The admission fee.
Okay, sir.
For example, there are multiple P heads.
If I have to take only one head fee,
then I will un-tick the other one.
Then proceed.
Here we have payment modes.
In which payment mode you have to collect.
By default, cash is used.
You can use check, demand draft, online bank transfer, anyone.
For now, as I have done it online,
I have a reference number and its date.
It is mandatory here.
For example, I have given a reference number here.
And I have mentioned the date here today.
Which transaction date is mine.
Then collect fees.
And I have done okay.
So my receipt will be generated.
The admission fee for April month was 18,000 rupees.
And I have paid 18,000 rupees.
So there is no due pending in admission fees.
Clear?
Yes, sir.
So this will be the collection.
What did we do for this?
It was 9-7.
I have collected only for April month.
Now what the parent is saying is
I have to collect everything till March month.
If I want to pay the entire amount,
I will click on all.
All the installments will show up.
Okay, sir.
So if I proceed like this,
I will receive the entire amount.
If I select the payment mode and collect the fees,
I will receive 60,000 rupees.
Okay?
So by selecting the terms from here,
we can pay the complete fees.
And also the partial amount.
Yes, sir.
So this is the fee collection.
Now if there is any doubt in the fee collection,
if I have to do it in one head,
if I have to deduct the amount from multiple heads,
is there any doubt in that?
Or I just have to edit the amount here.
All three are clear?
Yes, sir.
Sir, after proceeding like this,
the date mentioned during the collection,
if by chance we are receiving the amount from the cheque,
then the date mentioned will be the same as today
when we have received the cheque.
In the case of cheque,
if you have a cheque and it is 18 today,
the cheque will not be received on the same date.
Yes, sir.
The cheque will be received one or two days earlier.
So the cheque also has a reference number
and its date is always one or two days earlier.
Okay, sir.
So that date you will mention is your payment date.
The date you have received the payment
and this date you have made a transaction in ERP.
Both are different.
Yes, sir.
Sir, the payment date will be like when we are receiving the amount.
Absolutely.
The transaction date is when you have entered in ERP.
Okay, sir.
What is the meaning of collect online fees
when we integrate the payment gateway?
After that, through the app or we click from here.
It is coming here.
Right now the payment gateway is not integrated here.
So this will keep loading.
Okay.
If we integrate the payment gateway,
then we can also collect online payments from here
by generating our own dynamic QR code.
Whatever is valid for time,
parents can also pay from here.
Yes, sir.
I will show you this on live.
So I have options like UPI, net banking and credit card.
I can pay from these modes.
When I click on pay,
I will also generate a QR code.
I can also pay by UPI.
So I have generated a QR code.
When I click on scan,
I can use Paytm, Google Pay or whatever app we use
to pay from here.
This is showing the time.
After how much time it will be disabled.
I have to pay between this time.
Okay.
Now I will cross this.
So next, we have done a collection.
Where can we check the collection?
I will show you that.
In fees, we have free reports.
Combined daily collection
and daily fee report.
These are two reports
where we show the collection.
First, combined daily collection.
Recip number.
Today's date.
What was the admission number of the student?
What is the student's name?
Class.
From which mode has the payment been made?
And these are some other details.
The payment was made from admission fee head
and only this amount has been paid.
So this detail is showing here.
Which user has paid?
That will also be shown here.
This is editable.
Whatever you add on the Excel template
will be shown here.
Like the roll number is showing at the end.
I don't want this.
I will remove it from here.
I will edit it.
So I am not showing the roll number.
So the client also has a requirement
that what I want in the reports.
We can set according to that.
Okay.
Now there is another thing.
Like admission heads.
If you have taken training
about admission module.
No sir.
There are admission heads in admission module.
For example, before students are approved,
some amount is paid in the school.
Like the prospectus fee or registration fee.
Then it is collected in admission head.
That admission head is also shown in the collection.
And in daily fee report and combined daily
there is a difference that admission heads
other income which is other than our fees
collection is also shown here.
In the daily fee report,
admission heads are not shown.
I will show you by editing.
There are miscellaneous heads.
But here admission heads are not shown.
So admission heads are not shown
in the daily fee report.
In the combined daily collection,
admission heads are also shown.
Other income heads are also shown.
If you have seen the fee setup.
In the fee setup,
we make other income remarks.
Yes sir.
Other income heads.
So these other income heads,
they are shown here.
When we collect other income,
the collection in the other income
is also shown in the combined daily collection.
Other income, admission, miscellaneous and P heads.
Means we can see all the collections
in the combined daily collection.
There is a major difference
between both the reports.
Yes sir.
Any doubt?
In both?
No sir.
Do you know how to cancel the receipt?
If by chance the receipt of the cult amount is cut,
then how can I cancel it?
No sir.
Now as I have cut the receipt,
there is one option.
I can go to the fee transaction list
and cancel it from here.
In other, I will give a remark
on why I am cancelling it.
If I save it, the receipt will be cancelled.
So that will be shown in the daily fee report
and in the cancellation report.
I will filter it for cancellation.
In status, cancel.
Now I don't have any data
in the cancellation report.
In the daily collection, I have data.
In confirm, I have data
but I don't have any data in the cancellation report.
Because I have selected status cancel.
Okay?
The next report we have is
the fee head collection report.
Yes sir.
But you had previously shown us a cancel.
I haven't done that.
I haven't saved it.
Okay sir.
The fee head collection report.
In the fee head collection,
we can see the day-wise or monthly-wise
fee head collection.
Means the day-wise collection
that has been collected today,
the collection of the scores,
the collection of the sessions,
we can see that.
Like today, on 18th June,
in online mode,
18,000 rupees have been collected
in admission fee.
So that is showing here.
I can check monthly
that I have to see only June month.
I have done that.
Now in June month, I have
in multiple payment mode,
31,000 in admission,
25,000 in tuition,
and 500 in miscellaneous.
If I want to do this mode-wise
differentiate,
I have selected mode here.
I have done that.
So here I have
mode-wise differentiated.
How much has been collected in cash?
How much has been collected online?
And how much has been
adjusted to amount?
The meaning of amount adjust
is that I have collected
in one fee head.
I did not have to collect in that head.
I had to show the collection
in some other head.
So I have adjusted it
from one head to another.
This is called fee adjustment.
Okay, sir.
Next is daily payment mode collection.
Today's collection
is in which mode?
That will be shown
in daily payment mode collection.
If you want to check
only payment mode collection,
there will be different
different payment modes.
You can filter out
from which date you want to check.
From that date to
the last date,
it will show in which mode
collection.
Next we have due fee report.
In due fee report,
in class 5.
So I will show you class 5.
I have to check
only April month
of all fee heads
that how much due is pending
only for active students.
So here I have
all active students
their due
in April month.
If I want head wise due,
I can also check
head wise due.
So my total due is 23,000
in 18,000 admission fees
and 5,000 tuition fees.
So my head wise due
is also showing.
The student whose
receipt was cut,
his admission fee is also showing 0
because 18,000 rupees
has been received here.
So this pending
dues will show you here
in due fee report.
Is there any doubt
in the reports so far?
No sir.
This is due fee report.
We can also see due fee report
course wise.
You can select
which course you have seen here.
This is used for teachers.
If we have given
this right to the teacher,
he can check his own course from here.
But we have this option
of due fee report.
So we have all the courses coming here.
Next is multi-session
due fee report.
What does this mean?
The due fee report
that you have to see, you can see
in multiple sessions
that how much due is pending.
There is no one in this show
24-25
or 25-26.
You can check from here
the amount after which
you have to see the due.
Suppose I have to see
25-100 rupees.
So the dues above that
will be shown here.
Okay?
Means from which percentage
you have to check the dues.
From which percentage or amount.
If you see the due fee report
of only class 50.
Here you have the option
of the enter amount
and the enter percentage.
Means you can mention the percentage
of the dues here.
When you go,
it will show you the amount
or more than that.
I will tell you the use of this.
For example, 10,000 rupees
more than that
of the dues,
only that should have the message.
This is what the client is saying.
Then we select them
and send whatsapp
or send due fee.
Whatever they have integrated
according to that we can send the message.
You can write the amount
here.
When you click on go,
the amount will show more than that.
That much or more than that.
Okay sir.
Next is the concession report.
Before checking the concession report,
I will show the student
one by one.
You must have done this
when you set up the fee.
Have you created a concession group there?
Yes sir.
For example, I have created
10% concession here.
I want this only in March
or PAB.
I have added it here.
Percentage concession type
and in PAB and March
I have made a concession of 10%
Click on add.
Student profile
I have opened the second one.
Concession fees.
From here I have selected
the concession group.
Automatically the concession
amount is coming here.
10%
Demand was 5000 rupees.
So according to 10%
500 concessions have been created.
Next, remark
is coming automatically.
10% concession.
You can edit this
and mention whatever you want to type here.
When I saved here
the concession was
assigned to the student in PAB and March.
If you
look at the collective fee page
1000 concessions
are showing here.
We can check this in the fee report
and concession report.
In PAB and March
1000 rupees tuition fee concession
is showing. This is the concession report.
Now
I am
checking here
in the institute setup
course.
I have a batch coming here.
Where do we use the batch
in the case of school
or colleges?
In the case of colleges and universities.
Now if I want to remove the batch
from here, how will I remove it?
By going to the institute preferences.
Yes sir.
We can go to the display and change it.
We will remove the batch from there.
And in the fee
we will untick the include batch
box.
We will go to the fee and scroll down.
Include batch.
Yes sir.
And in the display name
we will remove the batch too.
We haven't done that.
Yes sir.
We removed the include batch.
Because we did it that time.
I have opened this
from Sanjo. You must have
worked somewhere else.
Yes sir.
What is the meaning of this?
Sir like if extra fee
like I am not sure but
if we pay extra fee
then if we include it then
it will auto adjust.
Maybe it will mention extra fee.
It auto adjusts
Yes sir.
Now if I have
collected 18,000 rupees
I have put it in concession
here in manual.
Assume 10,000 rupees
for admission fee.
And I am saving it.
So it is saying that the amount has already been received.
So 10,000 rupees
will go in extra fee.
If I ok it then what will happen?
Sir there will be a fee head
in which this amount will add on.
I have ok it.
I have
an extra transaction
here.
I will show you the first transaction.
In the first transaction
10,000 admission fees
will go in extra fee
after concession.
Ok?
In the second transaction
those 10,000 rupees
which were in extra fee
will be adjusted
in April-May tuition fee.
Why did this happen?
Because that toggle was on
auto adjusts extra fee.
Sir why did this happen
in that particular fee head?
Why didn't it happen in other cases?
If the receiving had already come
from before
then it wouldn't have happened.
There are only two heads here.
The collection has already been done in admission.
Only tuition fee pending.
Yes sir.
So whatever
the first
view will be in the heads
it will show the collection in that.
It will get 5,000 rupees
here, 5 here
and it will adjust 10,000 rupees
here.
So these 10,000 rupees have been auto-adjusted here.
It is also written here.
It is an auto remark.
Yes sir.
This is its meaning.
Sir how can we discuss this once?
I don't understand.
Like
the extra fee
that has gone
Wait a minute.
First we have to do the upper one.
Now what happened?
I cancelled both the receipts.
Okay?
So the concession that I had put for 10,000 rupees
came in negative here.
Why did it come in negative?
Will you tell me once?
Sir we had already done
and I had put 10,000
in the concession
so it means
only 8,000 should have been collected in the admission fee.
But it was 18,000.
Okay.
Now I will show it
once again.
By removing the concession.
I have removed it.
Now it will not come in negative there.
I have done it like before.
Now I will put the concession again
manually.
I have put 5,000.
Saved it.
It has already been adjusted.
It will not come in negative.
I will show it to another student.
Now in the student's cash
we have received 15,000 rupees.
So if I sign the concession
here.
5,000 rupees.
Saved it.
So it is telling me that the already received amount
will be adjusted in future
installment or it will be moved to
2,000 rupees extra fees.
So I have made it okay.
So I have 2,000 rupees
deducted from the tuition fee.
Same thing.
2,000 rupees extra fee.
And extra fee
2,000 rupees deducted from the tuition fee
of April month.
Now is it clear?
Yes sir.
Sir in case like in our present
there is no one. Then it will be deducted
from next month.
Then it will be deducted from next month.
If all this is clear from here.
There is no amount.
Then it will be deducted from July month.
Okay sir.
Then fee summary.
We can see fee summary course wise,
category wise, head wise.
I will tell you about head wise first.
If we want to see head wise
of active students.
What is fee head wise summary?
Of different courses.
So in admission fee
there was so much demand.
So much concession that we invested 5,000 rupees.
So much payable
concession
was deducted.
So much receiving and so much
balance pending.
This is fee summary head wise.
Head wise we can see fee summary
in today's date.
Okay sir.
If you want to see course wise
I have done it.
Class one
and class five.
One or two students of class one
and class five students are here.
So after demand
as much concession, as much payable
and how much received.
And after that the balance pending
I have fee summary
in class five.
I can also see category wise.
What is the means of category?
Which is our admission category.
Which is only general.
If it was different
then there would be different
category wise amount.
If there is only one then there is only one.
What is the meaning of fee summary group wise?
If we have made fee head
group also.
It is used in colleges case if
there is no group in it.
Combined head wise
we can see fee summary of multiple head.
Okay sir.